weekend edition a special benefit is
happening tonight to help entertainers
who've struggled throughout the pandemic
welcome back vegas is taking place at
stoney's and town square
madison kimbrough joins us live there
and madison it really seems like a cool
concept
it really is sasha you know here at
stoney's country rocking bar here at
town square
i'll tell you there are live performers
here entertaining for
free just because the struggle has been
so hard
during the pandemic now take a look as
we took shots earlier
all in hopes of raising money for these
struggling artists the hope is that this
will be a
reoccurring event and more entertainers
can perform to a live
audience once again the event that
started at 7 00 or at 4pm excuse me will
last
until 7 and have several different acts
that will also be available through
pay-per-view
now a bar that will be set up for drinks
is already available
and there will be plenty of space for
people to dance and mingle
organizer marty b says this is an event
he just had to be a part of
they are born entertainers that's what
they do they
that's their life that's their
livelihood and it just made me so sad
so i just started reaching out to all my
friends that i'm friends with
entertainers saying hey
let's do an event you know let's get
some money in your pocket
now if you're unfamiliar with stony's
it's a country bar but the acts tonight
will offer a variety of musical and
comedic entertainment
and according to marty this is just a
small step in the right direction for
the entertainment capital
of the world so again a mission is free
and this lasts until 7 pm
it really is a great concept a great
event to come on out and see these
entertainers live
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now